hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion on October 24th 2023 a crowd
gathered in an event Hall in Hawaii they
were at a conference for the chip design
firm Qualcomm rumors were churning that
something big was coming the crowd was
chattering among themselves in
anticipation but within a few minutes
everyone in that audience would be
stunned no what did he just say that
their chips were faster than the chips
from Apple and Intel and it uses less
power how could this be possible the
speaker Cristiano Amon qualcom president
and CEO could read the stunned faces of
the audience and he stated in his thick
Brazilian accent yes take a photo take a
photo our Ryan CPU exceeds the M2
Max
[Applause]
and it's faster than any Le leading arm
compatible competitor in a single traded
CPU performance take a photo take a
[Applause]
photo this was the biggest single event
in the tech Hardware space since Apple
began to design their own custom chips
for their MacBooks back in 2020 but as
the ultimate twist in this story the
people who designed this new magical
qualcom chip were in fact ex-apple
engineers and they took all their trade
secrets with them in all of this there's
a lawsuit going on but it's not from who
you would expect after qualcomm's
bombshell announcement it's now come to
light that Microsoft Lenovo HP Dell Asus
and Samsung are all going to use
qualcomm's new chip to power some of
their laptops but it wasn't over in a
matter of days Apple hit back with a
surprising unveiling of a new chip but
the thing is according to early
benchmarks Apple's M3 is still beaten by
Qualcomm in some cases and don't worry
we'll check that out too overnight the
Computing industry has just gotten very
interesting we're going to get into all
of this in this
[Music]
episode you are watching cold fusion
TV a bit of background for all of modern
Computing history computer
microprocessors have generally fallen
into two categories x86 chips and arm
chips x86 chips are what you usually
find in Windows desktops laptops and
even Macs until 2020 x86 chips are
generally complicated use a lot of power
but they were flexible and performed
well the major players in the x86 space
are Intel and
AMD arm is a British firm that licenses
their chip designs for modification by
other brands arm licensing chip designs
will come into play near the end of the
episode arm chips are what you'd expect
to find in phone and tablets arm
architecture is extremely efficient
simpler in design but were traditionally
weaken performance in comparison to
x86 that's the way it was and the way it
always would be until things were
flipped on their head in 2020 when Apple
did The Impossible they essentially
scaled up a modified iPhone chip to
reach desktop performance in other words
they designed a mobile arm chip with x86
desktop performance I made a video on
this and said that this was a change in
the Computing industry one year after
the success of Apple's M1 chip qualcom
decides to buy a fresh startup made up
of EX Apple Engineers but we'll get to
that part of the story later but at the
end of the day the result of this fresh
Talent from Apple was qualcom coming
through from nowhere to outperform
Apple's M2
Chip we are embarking on this journey
and our goal when we set ourselves to
develop the CTU is to set the bar for
the industry and established the
performance leadership for Windows PC we
have
delivered and I have to tell you we
exceeded our own
expectations so based on the
announcement today I'm very pleased to
tell you that there is a new sheriff in
town the Orion CPU is the new leader and
mobile Computing period has been
designed
W it's been designed by qualcon from the
ground up with one thing in mind can we
have unprecedented level of performance
at extremely low power it's faster than
any leading armed compatible competitor
in a single traed CPU performance take a
photo take a
photo I'm sure you want to take the next
photo too you
know if you want to
match if you want to match that
performance he can do with 30% less
power isn't that
[Applause]
incredible okay but if we say that is
the new CPU leader for mobile Computing
period uh I have to show you more so
it's faster than leading x86
CPU single traded CPU performance of the
core exceeds the I9 13980 HX which is
designed for high performance gaming
device okay get ready for the next photo
that's going to be
good and if you want to match the
performance it does a
70% less
power the YouTube channel Gary explained
goes over some early benchmarks when
compared to Apple's M2 which keep in
mind is a year old at this point so what
we're seeing here is the best single 3
Performance is from the Snapdragon X
Elite even when it's running in that 23
watt mode that's better than the M2 Pro
that you get in a MacBook Pro and even
better here when you bump it up to even
that higher thermal budget and of course
multicore does depend on the number of
cores you've got uh and then you've got
the M2 Pro this is of course the big one
that everyone's in their mind now it is
slightly faster than the Snapdragon X
Elite when you're running it's 23 WT
mode but not when you bump it up to 80
wat it'll be interesting to see what
laptops corcom Partners release uh you
know next year to see what kind of uh
wattage we're going to have the tech
world was stunned an antech rights quote
if nothing else the introduction of a
clean sheet high performance CPU design
makes Orion the most interesting story
in Hardware Tech right now and the most
interesting thing to happen in the CPU
space since the introduction of Apple's
M1 and if the Snapdragon X Elite as a
whole can deliver on the performance
claims CPU GPU and npu that makes things
all the more interesting the fact that
we're talking about the Snapdragon X
Elite in the same breath as the M2 or
rapto lake is a major achievement for
qualcom and the competition is heating
up Nvidia and AMD have also mentioned
plans to get into the arm-based PC space
But as we all know things weren't over
the very next week Apple hits back by
announcing the M3 chip so the question
has to be asked so how does Apple's
latest chip compete with the Qualcomm X
Elite well we don't have all the data
yet at the time of writing the X Elite
so far has been seen in benchmarks in
the wild running two versions a low
power 23 wat version and a high power 80
W
version for context the Bas M3 uses 25 W
of power and the M3 Max uses 30 W of
power
so take this with a grain of salt
because it's not the full picture but in
single core performance the 80 WT
version is unsurprisingly the fastest
cuz it uses the most power while the 23
W version of the X Elite is defeated by
all versions of the M3 multi-core is a
different story though the 80 wat ex
Elite is beaten by the M3 Max by 19% but
still manages to outpace all other
versions while the 23 W version of the
ex Elite sits in between the bass M3 and
the M3 Pro
so how did Qualcomm do all of this so
suddenly well basically as you know they
poached the talent from Apple it all
begins with the establishment of the
Navea team in 2019 so what is NAA I hear
you asking well they're basically a
company founded by John Bruno Manu Gatti
and Gerald Williams III these guys are
the who's who of Chip design at Apple
they were key highlevel Architects
behind many generations of Apple's
iPhone
processors Williams was the key
architect on all of Apple's CPU designs
including the recent lightning core in
the a13 the three founders combined have
over 100 pents related to systems
engineering and silicon design other
accolades of the founding team include
engineering leadership roles at Google
Apple arm broadcom and AMD the company
aims for an upheaval in the industry
which they describe in their own words
as a quote step function increase in
compute performance and power efficiency
normally someone could just say this is
all marketing hype but their Stellar
track record and what they've just done
proves that this is the case after
seeing what Apple did with the M1 they
purchased Nava in January of 2021 for
$1.4 billion after this they folded the
company's Technologies into their road
map for future chips and the ex Elite is
their very first product and I think
that's remarkable in my opinion the
purchase of Navea by Qualcomm will go
down as a turning point for the company
and perhaps the industry as a whole as
mentioned earlier Microsoft Lenovo HP
Dell Asus and Samsung are all getting on
board and using Qualcomm in some of
their upcoming laptops now all that has
to happen is Microsoft taking windows on
arm seriously once this is done things
could get really exciting as a side chip
designers leaving Apple to start their
own startups reminds me of back in the
1960s when Fairchild semiconductor
Engineers moved off throughout Silicon
Valley to create startups one of these
companies was Intel so I have to wonder
is history rhyming speaking of Intel
what's going on with
[Music]
them well they're releasing their new
generation of laptop chip but so far
according to what we know Intel's new
laptop processes dub meteor Lake offers
a slight Improvement of what Intel is
currently offering and AMD but they do
prioritize power efficiency and all day
battery life Intel has announced its
hotly anticipated 14th gen core Ultra
meteor Lake based processors will launch
on December 14th the new CPUs offer all
the performance of 13th gen Raptor L
chips with half the power draw with
meteor leag Intel finally joins its
competitors with its first CPU that uses
independently fabricated chiplets while
some of these tiles will be created
using Intel's bleeding edge Intel 4
process others will use tsmc's 5 NM
process the chips use a new type of
efficiency core Which Intel calls a low
power Island designed to handle light
workloads without powering up a more
energy hungry compute tile reportedly
doubling integrated graphics performance
per watt unfortunately for Intel amd's
Next Generation processes based on the
Zen 5 architecture are just around the
corner and they're expected to perform
better okay so lastly what about this
lawsuit well according to Bloomberg the
British firm arm quote accused Qualcomm
of building on technology it acquired
from Nua without negotiating a new
license Qualcomm filed a counters suit
claiming that it's done nothing unlawful
and that arm can't demand that it
destroy processor chip technology built
with Nava's intellectual property and so
with that armed laptops are venturing
into the mainstream and apple will have
some great competition on their hands in
a year or two this is ultimately great
for consumers and I'll be watching
closely from the sidelines so what do
you guys think feel free to discuss in
the comments section below anyway that's
about it from me if you want to watch my
previous episode on how Apple changed
the industry back in 2020 I'll leave a
link to it below and at the end of the
video so thanks for watching my name is
toogo and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next episode cheers guys have a good
[Music]
one
cold fusion it's new
thinking